one of the country's largest coronavirus
outbreaks is inside an Ohio prison
almost 2,000 inmates at the Marion
Correctional Institution have tested
positive the virus has become a serious
problem in prisons and jails nationwide
Omar Villafranca spoke to family members
of inmates who worried about their loved
ones this video appears to show Alabama
inmates describing how easily the corona
virus could spread in the state's jail
system one shot appears to show close
sleeping quarters
Kylie herring is terrified for her 27
year old fiance Dillon James Hendricks
Hendricks is in an Alabama work-release
program serving time for stolen property
and drug-related charges he's up for
parole in June herring worries if
Hendricks who has severe asthma gets
covin 19 it will kill him she wants him
released early legally speaking is this
a civil rights issue is that flula civil
rights issue civil rights attorney Lee
Merritt says with the virus spreading in
jails some nonviolent offenders should
be released there is gonna be a time of
reckoning when this disease begins to
spread among people who have failed to
social distance and that is going to be
the prison system
Rebecca Fisher is an epidemiologist at
Texas A&M University she explains why
social distancing in jail or prison is
nearly impossible there are a lot of
opportunities for contact direct contact
with sick individuals and in direct
contact through objects and surfaces the
virus has exploded at the Cook County
Jail in Chicago if there's any symptoms
being shown by an individual we would
take that individual either Cook County
Sheriff Tom dart oversees to jail where
at least six inmates have died and
nearly 400 people have tested positive
despite stepped up cleaning efforts
closing their doors dart says is not an
option I certainly can't call the
Chicago Police Department say listen
those people you picked up for murder
last night those brutal murders yeah
just keep him locked up in your office
handcuff him to a desk you can't do that
are you worried as a mother Maria Valdez
begged for the early release of her 20
year old son Alex Sanchez locked up in
the Cook County Jail for a nonviolent
offense he spoke to us over the phone
while in jail about the conditions
Sanchez has an upcoming trial while he
waits for the date his attorney was able
to get him released from jail with an
ankle monitor and back home where he's
safe at last check 34 people tested
positive in the Dallas County Jail and
that includes at least 12 jail workers
essential employees people who were
coming to work every day and then going
home to their families now there was a
lawsuit filed against the Dallas County
Sheriff asking for the release of
certain vulnerable inmates Anthony
Oumar thank you